Queen Congrats on being the new queen of
auradon now you sure know how that
becomes and we have to say we're super
impressed with how you chose to take
down the barrier and let your fellow
UK's through this way you can continue
to form an awesome friendship with your
new pal
uma we totally noticed some sparks
flying between you two which is why
we're a little confused so come on now
cause the truth
whyever you and uma able to defeat
audrey Malan uma might be tight-lipped
about the whole ordeal but we want some
answer is why is it that aura now are
stronger together and why was a magician
necklace glowing for now keep watching
to find out we definitely weren't the
only ones confused about mal and umas
conjoined powers two villains from
opposite sides of the barrier united
forces and managed to be Audrey and
Maleficent scepter this would make sense
if it weren't for the fact that the
Disney descendants trailers confirmed
that the only thing strong enough to
beat Maleficent sceptre is Hades Ember
so we're a little confused as to why the
ember wasn't strong enough to beat
audrey but what and now were there are a
few theories that could explain this
strange phenomenon but for the most part
we do know why mal wasn't able to
overpower audrey on her own after all
Hades did Bournemouth at the ember is
100% dedicated to him and only 50%
dedicated to mal you're only half the
amber won't do everything for you that
it does for me and mal knew this which
is why she had Hades brought over from
the Isle to wake Audrey from her deep
slumber one of the more vanilla theories
out there is that true friendship defies
all odds
meaning that Malin umas bond was enough
to overpower any villain who came their
way true love and true friendship play a
huge hand in a string of fairy tales
Evie was able to break Audrey's curse
with true love's kiss and Anna was able
to save Elsa when she risks her life for
hers so in the magical world of Disney
it isn't too far-fetched to believe that
true friendship can defy all odds still
some of us aren't convinced that what
Emma a now have is true friendship after
all they were enemies for years so it
would take time for their bonds to
become selfless and true
so this theory doesn't exactly spark a
fire to everyone's hearts especially
since uma and mouse newfound friendship
was based on lies and black nah from the
get-go
uma conned her way into joining the core
force journey
whereas mal lied to Emma to get the c3
to help them take down Audrey another
possible theory is that two magical
beans are stronger than one both uma and
mal have magical parents and they're
both able to transform into some pretty
ferocious beasts so it's safe to say
that they're the strongest BK's in the
united states of auradon the first time
Mallon uma used their powers
simultaneously is during their fight
with the metal Knights now tries to use
a spell to overpower Audrey's curse but
is unsuccessful but when Malin umas
sword slash the curse is broken and now
is finally able to land her spell
something magical happens when Malin
umas swords collide but at this point in
the movie
uma is still holding on to the Ember so
it would make sense that maou is able to
draw strength from the Ember when her
sword collided with umas and since
Yuma's seashell necklace is super
powerful it might have joined forces
with the Ember at the exact moment in
time so if this theory checks out it
would mean that mal had it all wrong
Hades ember isn't the only thing that
can defeat Maleficent sector since
villains don't often work together it
would have been a little known fact that
Ursula's necklace and Hades ember could
combine to overpower maleficent scepter
so this got us thinking maybe Hades is
the only one who can beat Maleficent
sector because Hades can use his Ember
to its full potential
whereas mal cannot but half of Hades
ever Plus umas necklace is more than
enough to undo the scepters curse but
our last and most mind-blowing theory is
a lot more complex than the ones that
came before it
what if Emma's necklace had nothing to
do with mal but was actually reacting to
the ember we find out that mo is keeping
Hades ember inside her necklace when she
finally handed the Ember over to mal and
afterward mal has never seen using the
Ember on her own
tsylia soon throws it into the well
making it lose all of its powers at the
end of the movie
uma decides to trust mal again and they
combine powers to reignite the ember
which works like a charm
so here's our theory WA Niman now work
together they can use 100% of the embers
powers because well they're half sisters
but they just don't know it yet we don't
know who his father is but we do know
that Allah loves wearing the color aqua
blue we also know that hades walked out
on mal and maleficent when she was just
a baby so what if he ended up having a
fling with Ursula on the side we clearly
see the amber glowing in his hands but
only someone linked to the ember should
be able to do that so Malin uma are the
children of Hades they can use the invar
at half capacity each but when United
they can use it to its full potential
making them just as strong as Hades
which one of our theories make the most
sense to you sound off in the comments
section and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to the things
thanks for watching we'll catch you
later
[Music]